pancreatic cancer is a disease that
begins in one of your digestive organs
the pancreas it is located just behind
the stomach your pancreas is made up of
a head body and tail it contains two
main cell types one type called exocrine
cells produce digestive enzymes that are
secreted into tubes called ducts
the enzymes traveling through ducts
eventually empty into your small
intestine where they aid in digestion
the other type of pancreatic cell is
called an endocrine cell endocrine cells
are clustered in two groups known as the
islets of Langerhans
these cells produce the hormones insulin
and glucagon which are released into the
bloodstream to help control your blood
sugar level
pancreatic cancer starts as mutations of
pancreatic cells causing them to grow
very quickly and uncontrollably the
mutated cells will often clump together
to form tumors which can interfere with
the normal pancreas function like this
tumor most pancreatic cancers form in
the ducts and are called adenocarcinoma
x' or exocrine tumors
endocrine tumors which develop from
islets of langerhans are much less
common
your doctor will recommend treatment
based on the type of cell involved
location and stage of your cancer
treatment may include surgery radiation
chemotherapy targeted therapy or a
combination of treatments
you
there are three surgical options to
treat pancreatic cancer during a Whipple
procedure also called a
pancreatoduodenectomy your surgeon will
remove the head of your pancreas your
gallbladder and portions of your common
bile duct small intestine and stomach
the remaining structures will be
arranged in such a way to allow
continued digestion
in a total pancreatectomy your surgeon
will remove your entire pancreas common
bile duct gall bladder spleen and
surrounding lymph nodes as well as
portions of your stomach and small
intestine
during a distal pancreatectomy your
surgeon will remove the body and tail of
the pancreas as well as your spleen
radiation or radiotherapy uses
high-energy rays to kill cancer cells in
the treated area only
if the radiation originates from a
machine outside your body the treatment
is called external beam radiation
therapy radiation therapy placed inside
your body in the form of radioactive
pellets is called brachytherapy or
internal radiation therapy
chemotherapy uses drugs to stop the
progression of cancer by either killing
the cells or preventing further growth
systemic chemotherapy is taken by mouth
or an injection allowing the drugs to
travel through the bloodstream to reach
cancer cells throughout the body
regional chemotherapy involves the
injection of the drug into the arteries
surrounding the tumor allowing immediate
delivery to the cancer cells
targeted therapies focus on specific
abnormalities of cancer cells one
targeted therapy erlotinib is thought to
stop tumor growth by blocking chemical
signals that initiate cell growth and
division